Oh,
scientists and philosophers like to
think that they're a very sober,
rational people who are
above the need to advertise,
and yet if you look closely,
you'll see that they often go to great
lengths to come up with a vivid,
memorable term,
a label for their theory or a or a name
for it that will stick in people's
heads.
In other words,
they're trying to develop a brand name
or advertising or trademark for their
view,
and we should recognize that's a good
thing to do.
If you're going to run an example or if
you're going to run an argument,
try to make it
as easy as possible for the audience or
the reader to,
uh,
keep track of the elements.
Don't call them a,
b,
c,
D and e called him bill and Arthur and
Freddy and,
and,
and so forth.
But of course that could backfire on
Youtube,
um,
or it can be misused.
Uh,
one of my favorite bad thought
experiments,
bad intuition pumps is one in a very
influential paper by green and Cohen
published in the proceedings of the
Royal Society on what neuroscience tells
us about freewill.
And this is the boys from Brazil and in
this thought experiment,
a were to imagine this,
it's inspired by the hokey science
fiction film,
the boys from Brazil about some evil
doctors who who clone Hitler and they're
trying to make Hitler clones and but in
in this telling,
they create a human being who has been
designed by their evil intentions to,
to live a life of crime,
to do evil things,
but just as rational as anybody else,
he's very much controlled the sort of a
sort of a designed psychopath and they
call him Mr. Puppet
and they described Mr. puppet and Mr.
puppet goes out and commits a crime and
they appeal to the readers.
That to conclude that
Mr. Papa doesn't really responsible for
his,
for his evil deeds.
He shouldn't be punished.
Certainly he's just the victim of his
circumstances and then a blessed the.
They say now Daniel Dennett Mike Object,
that this is just an intuition pump and
that we shouldn't take it seriously.
Yes.
It's not that it's an intuition pump.
Intuition pumps can be good.
It's a.
it's a bad intuition pump.
And they said they just having noticed,
having imagined that I might be critical
of their pump,
they go ahead and do it anyway.
So let me now turn the knobs on this
intuition pump and we'll see what we can
make of it.
First they say the fact that this,
this person was created by evil
scientists with evil intent,
that's irrelevant to the example.
Really.
So,
all right,
so let's get rid of them.
We'll turn that in the oven.
So,
and the indifferent environment produces
a human being who,
uh,
they'd say by design is set out on a
sort of antisocial trajectory.
Well,
but we can get rid of that by design
too,
because if it's an indifferent
environment,
then there's no intent on this.
So we now we've got this,
an indifferent environment happens to
produce an individual who with high
probability we'll engage in some
criminal activities,
let's say.
And then they imagined that,
that he killed somebody in a,
in a drug bust or something like,
you know,
in a drug deal gone bad.
Well,
that's an essential.
So we're going to change the crime,
we're going to make it.
Um,
he killed somebody who's witnessed some
embezzlement that he's done,
shouldn't make any difference.
If you thought that the Mr Puppet in the
first instance wasn't responsible and
shouldn't be held responsible and that
this shouldn't change it.
Now I want to change just one more
thing.
They keep talking about Mr. Puppet.
Okay.
That's a nice vivid name,
but it's just a name shouldn't make any
difference.
I'm going to change it.
Let's call Mr. Puppet.
Oh,
captain autonomy.
Okay.
So now captain autonomy is caused by an
indifferent environment to enter on a
trajectory where becomes likely that
he's going to commit some anti social
behavior.
And uh,
uh,
now the question is whether he should be
held responsible.
Well,
I think captain autonomy,
why shouldn't he be held responsible?
Let me flesh it out a little bit more.
Um,
let's suppose it captain autonomy is a
Harvard graduate,
uh,
who goes to work at Lehman brothers and
he sees a clever way of embezzling a few
million dollars and has pulled off his,
his,
uh,
white collar crime when he discovers a
person who has about to,
to,
uh,
expose him.
And He,
uh,
Louis him to the edge of the balcony and
the high rise and pushes him off and he
falls to his death.
Now that's my case.
Now,
are we so clear that captain autonomy is
a,
is not responsible for his deed?
It seems to me that I drained the
example of most of the ones that
provided the intuitions.
I'm not saying that my retelling of it
shows that he is responsible.
I'm just pointing out that those details
which presumably are ad Lib and you
shouldn't,
they shouldn't make a difference.
They make a huge difference into how we
think about this person and whether or
not to hold them responsible.